انا شفت محل عين في قطنه يعني انا اجزم
انه انه صار انه اخذوا
[موسيقى]
اعضاء
لا توجد دوله في العالم ولا حتى عصابه
تحتجز جثامين وتساوم عليها تحتجز اسرائيل
جثامين الشهداء الفلسطينيين في الثلاجات
او في مقابر سريه تسمى مقابر الارقام يمنع
الدخول اليها وتعتبر مناطق عسكريه مغلقه
هذه المقابر هي مدافن بسيطه بدون شواهد
ومثبت فوق القبر لوحه معدنيه تحمل رقما
معينا ولهذا سميت بمقابر الارقام ارادت
اسرائيل منها ان يكون الموت بدايه معاناه
واداه انتقام وعقابا لاسرهم وشعبهم وورقه
للتفاوض والمساومه في انتهاك للقيم
الانسانيه والقوانين الدوليه هون موجود
قبر مفتوح لكن ابني موجود في مكان اخر
وابني اسير اسير شهيد من حقي اني اروح
ازور قبر ابني حتى لو بدعوا انها منطقه
امنيه كان في تباطؤ الارسال الى المستشفى
واقول لم يرسل الى المستشفى ممكن اخذوا
اعضاءه وممكن انه باعوا جثته للجامعات
والا اين
جثته ام ناصر ان
يستشهد احد انجالك او اثنان هم الان
مستشهدين وخمسه في الاصر هذه ماساه لكن ان
يتم احتجاز جثمانه ولا تتمكنين من دفنه ما
الذي يمثل ذلك بالنسبه لك كام ود ضحوا نظر
مشان الارض مشان فلسطين مشان الشعب
الفلسطيني مش عشان يستشهدوا جوا السجن
وياخذ الاحتلال يحتجزهم عنده شهدائنا مش
عرقهم هدول لازم يندفن في مقابر المسلمين
في فلسطين اللي ضحوا وناضلوا مشانها ما
الذي تقوله القوانين الدوليه فيما يخص هذه
القضيه تحديدا الطريقه التي نراها هي
تعتبر انتهاك لحقوق
الموتى عندما تكون الاسره لا تعرف ما حدث
لابنها هذه الامور هي تعتبر وحشيه وتتخطى
حتى ما بامكان العقل ان يتصور اعتبرت
اللجنه الفرعيه لمقاومه التعذيب في الامم
المتحده ان احتجاز الجثامين يرقى الى
مستوى التعذيب لانه تعذيب للاحياء وليس
[موسيقى]
للشهداء
نحن واثقون اننا في يوم ما سوف تنتصر عظام
الشهداء واشلاء على هذه
[موسيقى]
الغطرسه